a day after the killings
and the funerals begin the coffin of 13
year old saiwai
yen draped in the flag of the national
league for democracy
or nld on sunday although there were no
protests where he lived in yangon
the security forces still opened fire on
people
as buddhist monks led the funeral rights
friends and family
expressed their grief
why are you leaving me behind christ's
mother
inconsolable can't you hear me she says
how can i live without you my son
and the protesters continue to march
here in the city of darwin and southern
myanmar
people took to the streets with the now
familiar chance for the military to step
down
and there's no doubt now about the
reception that awaits them
the security service is fired with no
restraint on saturday
rubber bullets and live rounds from
automatic rifles
the pretence of protecting life and
liberty has been stripped away
and despite condemnation from around the
globe little
to make myanmar's military pause there
are a variety of steps that the world
can take
but they need to take these steps and
all the condemnation of the world
is not going to matter very much to the
people of myanmar
if they can't see the world standing up
and acting for them
as well as speaking out on behalf of
them
attitudes are hardening among the
protesters too in mandalay
they took air rifles to the barricades
on saturday
hardly a match for the weapons of war
they face
but now they know this is a fight to the
death
and more destruction after a fire raged
in pg dalgon township
overnight people living there but kept
away by security forces
returned to find 60 homes burned to the
ground
now all they can do is pick through the
ashes trying to save anything
from the military's policy of scorched
earth
tony cheng al jazeera chauwin is the
executive director of burma human rights
network and he says
imposing sanctions and an arms embargo
will be effective in myanmar
because it will take the wealth from the
military
regarding the military you know we uh we
welcome that the uk and u.s has now
you know targeting their economic
interests their conglomerates
and this is also affecting and
significantly on their
inside inside this inside their circle
and we are asking international
community for arms and burglary
and you see that yesterday also
frequently we have seen that
the the military is using air power to
bomb the civilian
villages in towns and in in ethnic
control area
so we are asking so for no-fly zone to
impose in those areas
because u.n must prove that u.n is alive
u.n is functioning in u.s
u.n has a capability to protect the
civilian
when you combine with the action like a
arms embargo no-fly zone
economic sanctions these are going to
affect
and this will be you know uh you know
bring down that that
ruthless regime because you see that
this military regime is not as strong as
we have seen in the past
in other part of the world that the you
know the dictators of course china and
russia is backing them
but china and russia will not risk for
them everything
is because china has a lot of interest
in burma which will not be secured by
you know by supporting the
the military the main aim of the
controlling power is
to to obtaining wealth to controlling
power that's the main goal for them
once their wealth is going going taken
away from them and they are not
achieving their goals
then this is a very effective move